So you might remember a little
while ago, we made a film
called, Lighting a Match with
Water, where we heated some
water and passed it through a
copper coil, and then used it
to light a match like this.
Stick it into the stream and
then withdraw it to allow the
air to get to it, and at that
point the match ignites.
So that was all a bit
complicated and it inspired
one of our YouTube followers to
leave a comment, which I'll
read to you.
He says, why not put a bit of
sodium on the end of the match
and then put a small drop
of water on it.
So basically, can we light
a match with just a
single drop of water?
I think is what he's
getting at.
So, the first thing I thought
was that it's a little bit of
a cheat because it's just kind
of using chemistry to light
the match, which is what the
match does anyway really.
But the second thing I thought
was, actually, I don't know
what would happen.
So I thought it would
be nice to find out.
Here's a huge lump of sodium
of which I'm going to cut a
very small piece off.
Nice silvery finish there.
So, I'm just going to--
We have to keep it under oil
because it's so reactive.
I'll try not to get sodium
on Bruce Hood's skull.
Oh well, it's all right.
So this is a little
piece of sodium.
Sodium is what's called an
alkali metal from group one of
the periodic table.
And all the alkali metals
are very reactive.
They react very strongly with
air, which is why they're
stored in oil in the
jar and in here.
But also very strongly
with water.
Wipe the oil off a bit and
then damp this down.
Throw it in here and we'll
see what happens.
It's very exothermic
so it melts.
So if you look-- so it's
a molten ball.
So what we saw there was, well,
first of all, the sodium
melted with the heat from
the exothermic reaction.
And secondly, we saw the flame,
which was from the
hydrogen that was liberated
by the reaction.
So the hydrogen came from the
water that the sodium was
reacting with, ignited with the
heat, and then the whole
thing burned for a while
and got so hot,
it eventually exploded.
The question is whether we can
transfer all that and get it
to happen on the
end of a match?
Just poke it down over, our
piece of sodium, like that.
I think this might
work, actually.
OK, so that was kind
of all right.
We managed to light the match
using the reaction between
sodium and water.
I guess it wasn't a whole lot
more practical than using the
copper coil and the boiling
steam, but there you go.
But we didn't manage to light it
with just a single drop of
water, it took quite a lot.
It would be nice to see
if we can do that.
So I think the next thing to
do is to move a little down
the periodic table.
So these are the alkali metals
here, so we just used sodium.
So next one on the list,
K for potassium.
So it's a lot like sodium
in a lot of ways.
It reacts very similarly, but
actually reacts even more
vigorously.
And that's because it's
outermost electron, which is
responsible for the reactivity,
is held on even
less strongly than it
is with sodium.
So we're going to do the same
thing we did before with the
potassium and we'll
see what happens.
So that was pretty good.
We lit the match with just
a single drop of water.
If anyone else has any ideas
for some useless or useful
experiments they'd like to
see us try in the prep
room, get in touch.